to your face and to the professional and
capable staff at dieter and our partners
throughout the state who are working
through historical volumes of
unemployment claims I want to extend my
sincere thanks for the work that you're
doing I'd like to start today with an
update on the unemployment insurance and
then I'll go over pandemic unemployment
assistance so if we could bring up our
unemployment insurance pie chart thank
you standard unemployment insurance of
course is for individuals who lose their
job up through no fault of their own
these are people who employers whose
employers paid into unemployment
insurance and who earned both and enough
wages and worked enough hours to be
eligible for benefits as of May 30th we
have five hundred and twenty nine
thousand six hundred and forty six total
claims that have been filed for standard
unemployment insurance on the UI envy
site of those claims one thousand one
hundred and sixty-six thousand four
hundred and twenty eight were not
eligible for standard unemployment
insurance of those eligible filers who
filed weekly claims two hundred and
seventy-six thousand four hundred and
eighteen or approximately eighty eight
percent of those eligible claims were
successfully paid that's a number that's
up from our previous week there were
nine thousand three hundred and six
filers to employers or who were employed
or were not eligible because they had
earnings for that week that was greater
than the weekly benefit amount this
could be people who got a job or were
paid out leave that was over their
weekly benefit amount five thousand six
hundred four claims had insufficient
hours and/or wages to be paid UI
benefits at least for this week's time
period thirty-eight thousand five
hundred individual claimants did not
file for the week this number is down
from previous weeks which is a good sign
these are folks who started but did not
finish the weekly claim or they never
started or they reported that they were
not going to file a claim for this week
federal law requires that filers file
weekly claims in order to receive
payment
finally there are 30 3310 pending claims
again this is another decrease from the
previous week
these are filers whose claims are being
held for because federal and state law
require dieter to adjudicate those
claims this number is down from previous
weeks and continues to decline as dieter
staffs up and works diligently on
resolving outstanding claims of through
human intervention and through automated
fashion dieter has paid out a total of
over three billion dollars and combined
unemployment benefits we continue to
actively look for types of issues that
we can make group technical changes and
release payments these changes have to
conform with the unemployment insurance
law and regulation there are some
flexibilities that approver and provided
by the Department of Labor and the
governor's emergency declarations that
we are using to and leveraging to
automate and process batch jobs now I'd
like to move on to a question and
answering questions that we've received
about kula and providing some data I'll
do my best to address these questions
that we've received and I also want to
let everyone know that we created a Pugh
a glossary of claim statuses and terms
that can be found at d2nv gov backslash
puah scroll to the bottom of the page
and you'll find our glossary first let's
look at the numbers and if we could take
a look at our puah chart that would be
helpful as of 7 a.m. today June 12th
there have been 1,000 or 116,000 996
initial puah claims successfully filed
with a total of 1 million and 58,000 447
weekly claims filed this data indicates
that from that 116 thousand plus initial
claims an estimated 35,000 600 claimants
have not filed me
we claim the percent of the initial
claims do not have weekly claim filings
just like with the UI or stun
appointment insurance Puka I'm it's
June's of the 80,000 plus eligible
claims dieter has paid forty seven
thousand five hundred and eighty two
individual claimants for a total of
three hundred and fifty five point eight
million in kueh and then to a federal
pandemic unemployment compensation
dollars of the remaining eligible unpaid
puah claims many have eligibility issues
that are being actively resolved
payments are being processed on a daily
basis 60% of the stop payments eligible
for puah and they're released for
payment as soon as we review them dieter
is constantly seeking ways to batch
process these lease payments as soon as
people are as soon as possible about 40%
of the unpaid claims are either
ineligible for puan or eligible for
standard unemployment insurance
according to the cares Act dieter must
ensure that puah claimants are not
eligible for standard unemployment
insurance prior to making pulip benefit
payments once dieter has determined that
a claimant is in fact eligible for Pula
we make we pay on the self attested
wages and adjudicate that precise wage
after the fact adjudicating wages on the
back end of a claim is not in standard
unemployment insurance but the cares Act
does allow for this flexibility and puah
and the department is using this option
many of the pool claims have been filed
have been identified as potentially
fraudulent dieter has implemented
various measures to proactively resolve
a freeze or skinny freeze payment and
investigate both known and suspected
fraud we are coordinating with other
states and entities to stop fraudulent
claimants or claims prior to payment
many individuals and organizations have
reached out with concerns about Pula and
standard UI fraud if you suspect fraud
please file a report with deters fraud
unit by visiting
DMV gov finally an estimated 35 thousand
600 initial claims have had no claims
filed and as I said before her federal
law claimants for both who and you I our
unemployment insurance must file weekly
claims for every week eligible for in
order for Dida to Peter to pay on those
claims okay we can take the chart down
and we can talk about some other
questions there are a variety of
different ways for pool claimants to
receive pool of funds dieter recommends
that either the direct deposit into an
FDIC banking institution or a dieter
issued debit card many guha claimants
requested debit cards and we have now
automated this process so all claimants
who requested debit cards have been
nailed their cards and moving forward
all claimants who request a debit card
will receive their card in the mail
within seven to date ten days of
submitting a claim we have received many
questions about the puah 21 day
requirement to provide documentation
this 21 day period begins at the date of
initial claim filing the requirement is
that claimants must provide
documentation with a 21 days to align
with the self attested wages on their
claim many claims have also asked about
their claim status that reads in
quotations puah other program
eligibility and quotations this is a
claim status that requires a dieter
representative to check for one or more
of the following prior prior to making
payment we must check for unemployment
insurance eligibility we must check on
the requirements and the ability to pay
federal pandemic unemployment
compensation we must check on wages that
are in another state we must check on a
potential for combined wage claims or we
must check on standalone unemployment
insurance eligibility in another state
federal law prevents claimants who are
eligible for UI from obtaining pool of
benefits dieter must determine if a
claimant has the potential to file for
an alternate based period claim that
would allow for them to get access to
regular unemployment insurance as I said
earlier we've discovered that about 40
percent of the claims with this status
are eligible for unemployment insurance
claimants will get an electronic
determination that tells them they don't
you've also received questions about
what a prima claimant should do if the
portal is not allowing them to backdate
their weeks this is a scenario that
occurs not for everyone but as a result
of the dates that a claimant enters for
their day that they separated from
unemployment individuals who want to
file weekly kinds back than the date
that they indicated they separated from
employment must call the Pugh a call
center and ask to have their claims back
dated claims can go back to the last
Sunday of the week that a claimant
separated from employment tens of
thousands of to a claimants have been
calling the Pugh a call center and
dieter his dieter has been made aware of
Robo callers that have been jamming our
phone lines our bender and our staff
have to put technology mobile callers
from getting through with the hopes that
this will allow many more calls to be
connected to a customer service
representative deters or to a vendor is
actively recruiting erring or excuse me
call center vendor is actively
recruiting hiring and training call
center representatives and adjudicators
to assist with the high volume of claims
that we are currently working through a
few more general updates the Employment
Security Division is actively hiring and
training staff for the unemployment
division to assist with claims
adjudication and for fraud detection on
standard unemployment claims between the
cloud-based phone system implementation
that is currently actively being
implemented the hiring of additional
staff and the resolution we've had with
our phones
services providers dieter has seen a
standard you iphone q stay open for
longer periods of time resulting in more
calls getting through to claim staff on
a daily basis as the state works to
refit to phase in our reopening dieter
is closely working with our well of
course development not partners
throughout the state we're ready and
working on assisting Nevadans to get
back to work the department will begin
reporting on these efforts in our weekly
press briefing in the weeks moving
forward one final thing for the best way
for your unemployment insurance and puah
claimant to find up-to-date information
on their claim is to log into their
account at either you inv
for a standard unemployment insurance or
employee envy for puah
unemployment assistance we continue to
work on refining our guidance and other
documentation and we're working closely
with our IT staff to explore
technological solutions that we can
leverage to provide a better service
delivery to our two Nevadans thank you
for your continued interest in
collaboration and Rosa if there are
other questions I should answer please
let me know are you ready to take
questions now yes I am I can hear you oh
great thank you
our first question is from Jaclyn
Schultz of kvv you uux you previously
explained to lawmakers how the pending
UI cases are among the most difficult to
resolve and why a completion date is a
moving target could you please elaborate
on why this is the case yes thank you
Jaclyn so the existing bucket of folks
who are waiting and pending adjudication
the bulk of those individual claims have
separation issues so for the whatever
reason they separated from their
employment either their employer is
disputing the separation and disputing
unemployment
it's or there is some other complicated
requirement for us to adjudicate and
speak with individual order to determine
whether or not we can make payment so
that's what I'm saying when I'm talking
about the existing claims being someone
is tricky when I'm talking to lawmakers
about our adjudication timeline it
changes daily because we're continuing
to add additional staff who are being
trained actively on adjudicating claims
and we're working on automated
processing for adjudicating claims in
batch fashion so there is no distinct
time line that I can provide because
we're continuing to speed up these
processes on a regular basis thank you
so much okay our next question is from
Michael Shaara with the review journal
you did already touch on this director
regarding the expansion of staff for a
lorica and ours but the additional
question from Michael is is dieter and
Orca call centers thinking about or
considering to change hours of operation
from receiving calls to help with the
volume right now we're working on
primarily making sure that calls can get
through by implementing new phone
systems by addressing technological
issues where Robo colors were jamming in
may be continuing to GM the pool lines
and hiring additional staff thank you
our next question is from Sabrina Hudson
at the review journal a lot of a lot of
people are having issues connecting with
adjudication not just pool filers could
you provide an update with regards to
adjudication as the data I showed
earlier for unemployment insurance we
have a pending issues of about 33,000
Plus that is currently being worked on
both through our automated and with our
adjudication unemployment insurance
staff
with kuwae we are working on paying out
claims attorney final eligibility and
that is actively happening all day every
day in a combination factor with both
our D der staff and the adjudication
staff with allarakha and and so we like
both charts that we provided earlier
give it a good picture of what that
looks like
thank you very much could you elaborate
on on the difference between for
clayman's about applying for pool
eligibility for pool and UI do they have
to apply for one first versus the other
so the cares Act requires that the
Department and all states determine
whether or not an individual is eligible
for any unemployment insurance whether
it's in our state or another state prior
to allowing for a pool of payment and so
individuals must be file I mean they if
you believe yourself to file or to be
eligible for fewer than please file a
claim and subsequent weekly claims and
if the determination from our staff is
that you are more eligible for more
likely eligible for unemployment
insurance and we'll make sure to notify
you as such however we are accepting as
a form of documentation any kind of
denial for UI benefits in the pool of
portal and we recommend that you upload
that as your documentation thank you
very much so one of the other questions
is regarding the about the call volumes
on the allarakha hotline
are calling in and they the way for a
certain time and then they get hung up
could you elaborate as to how that
particular sister marks the call center
at ellora is a constant refinement work
in progress and you're working closely
with them to try to find ways to ensure
that that legitimate callers are getting
through and that Robo callers are not
jamming all of our lines so we recommend
that if you don't get through the first
time that you follow the IVR menu and
call back as per the direction and then
our final question is still cannot books
are still cannot get through so and I
believe you touched this on your
presentation slightly is the best method
or methodology for contacting in front
of claim representatives for puah
still through the call center yes that
is correct yes okay thank you that's all
I've got okay all right well thank you
everybody and we look forward to seeing
you again next week